Regal Cinema is announcing that dozens
of their locations will soon close their
doors including one location right here
in town in Las Vegas now many are
wondering about the future of the
industry with a whole lot of people
streaming movies at home instead of the
theater Sasha Loftus joins us live
downtown on this windy night tonight
with more on theater's efforts to adapt
now Brian a lot of people have been
talking about this for years whether or
not the future of movie theaters is in
play now those in the industry say it's
just a different opportunity this local
theater here downtown says they offer a
lot more than just a place to watch a
movie
I don't like seeing stuff like this
close down Mark Lombardi is soaking up
time at the Ville Square Regal Theater
while he can this was one of the main
ones we'd always come to the location at
Sahara and Fort Apache is one of 39
Regal Cinemas set to close across the
country months after the movie Giant's
parent company filed for bankruptcy
it's a move that's brought the future of
traditional Cinemas to the Forefront as
many still choose to stay home and take
advantage of streaming services we like
to be more than a movie theater
statistics show it's all still bouncing
back after covid shutdowns which means
local spots like Art House downtown are
doing their best to evolve really what
drives people to come back is the
experience director of operations Sean
Barracks says the key to his theater's
success is a focus on things you can't
get at home like gourmet meals and
special events we have the restaurant we
have the bar we do events we have you
know UFC watch parties golden knights
watch parties so while things aren't
what they were years ago
I think they'll always be around people
still want to go in the theaters and see
movies it looks
lines out are here to stay
Sean here at Art House tells me that a
lot of movie companies are actually
going back to theater releases first
this year as opposed to going on
streaming services right away now as for
the Regal Theater closures those are set
to start on February 15th reporting live
downtown tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now